so today we're only looking at half of
books three of the maker mechanics and
why is that if you've read ahead you
realize that the second half of the book
they actually starts going off in
different direction right and starts
talking about specific virtues and vices
those concerned with courage those
concerned with temperance
you know we're going to examine those
separately and another session so today
we're looking at this this section
that's really self-contained it has to
do with certain key ideas
what's all interior what's chosen and
another way of thinking about this is
what are we actually responsible for if
you think about it again it's often
helpful to compare us to other kinds
beings findings drop this pin does is it
choosing is there any voluntariness
about that whatsoever if its owner is
sort of an external compulsion the earth
is attracting it that's it there's
there's nothing more of the story I mean
you could say plants you know what a
plants do with with sunlight
the absorbent it's part of their process
of photosynthesis where they grow does
the plants name that's it now today I
need to photosynthesize better put it on
my to-do list you know that's part of
its nature it just automatically does
that right and we have things like that
and us did any of you have to think
right now about breathing to do your
probably to die if you can to the point
where you have to tell yourself to take
a breath take another one that's it
you're done because you know between
them and then once you have to start
thinking about it be dead heart I think
the heartbeat you'll never get around
with things like digestion or other
processes we have these automatic
automatic nervous response is that
college right part of autonomic nervous
system etiquettes it's called are you
responsible for that if you if you
breathe a little fast from time to time
via high blood pressure I mean you could
say you're responsible for high blood
pressure when couldn't you me like for
instance I once got those not exactly
diagnosis my doctor was concerned
because I you know they always check you
for high blood pressure as soon as you
come in yeah that particular day I was
sick I drank two pots of coffee and
eating anything all day long and I had
to drive across town get there was a
train I was
I don't like being late so my heart is
more agitated so I get in there and I
was like 140 overnight which is you know
a little high yeah now once you around
the radar now how are you you're
supposed to get checked so I told them
there's reasons why my blood pressure is
high this is anomalous and I said well
sorry we have our protocols we has a
chance so every day for a week my hands
the next day at the time who was a nurse
she would check my blood pressure
okay now what if I was a cat person who
is always eating Twinkies would I be
more responsible for my high blood
pressure what if I doesn't can a person
who is always surfing the internet for
stuff that tipped me off
did you know any people like that no I
and they often tend to be a little that
would be someone responsible for my
blood pressure but for the most part
we're now right and you could have
gotten the good genes in the genome
otteri or you could have gotten bad
genes so some of you may have intense
opposed diabetes some of you may not in
my mom's my adopted family my mom's died
they all tend to keep their teeth until
old age
these 90s but there's so that's good
alright there's also a lot of bipolar
disorder that's if you are born into the
family where your genes dictate these
sorts of things are you responsible for
them
are you possible for beings apology well
I guess if you know since you didn't
like start smoking cigarettes when you
were eight you know and it's not your
role in a sense you're responsible for
not being shorter but after you're tall
I'm tall
does anybody responsible for being being
shorter than you know I mean did you did
you have a choice did you say I'd like
to get another four inches to my height
I don't wear like you know shoes to do
that or anything I'll put myself on the
rack and stretch myself is that the sort
of thing that we can actually do you're
born with the body that you're born with
with the capacities that you have and
those are those are not within your
power nothing about the animals so we
get away from all this vegetative stuff
I don't things started to get a little
bit more voluntary with all the animals
responsible for some of the things we
certain animals do we look against
responsible for anything they're
basically just like protein robots
about learning responses these good
morning things actually turns out not
much but you know that's mostly honey
related thanks for nectar relationships
but they they can learn a little bit
what about your dog of your cat you ever
considered responsible
let's say you have a cat you don't
change the litter for a week where you
have a dog and keep the dog inside all
day all night
what's the likely result they're gonna
make a mess but is the dog responsible
for that if you didn't want the dog out
or the cat if you later
now what is the dog what if you actually
do let the dog in and out yeah if you do
clear the catheter and the cat you know
still like looking there any action it
goes over and say he's right
now when you start to think it's a bit
more responsible or anything to get into
the log and account is it in the dog's
nature to necessarily attack the cat
does the do I have to they're raised
together say it's a puppy a kid right
and some days the dog doesn't so amazed
the dog doesn't
some days the dogs not some mess with
the cat the days it doesn't you hold the
dog responsible don't you say and or
you're saying that it's voluntary in
some respects the dog on some level can
choose now the dog district feelings
like are we necessarily dominated by
that's where we get to a higher level
right what about us we have wean because
it don't certain things certain things
can I put food in front of you and tell
you don't eat it and walk out of the
room and come back in 20 minutes later
and you were there
sometimes I think it Walker your reasons
right I want to test you this is part of
an experiment okay
20 minutes lifetime food is soonerlater
that dog is beneath that food there are
certain capacities of its nature that
are just exhausting by that whereas we a
lot more control only and this is where
we know this issue virtues and vices and
choices and deliberation why are we
interested in all this this talk about
responsibility and choice well part
because we're doing virtue ethics and
virtue ethics virtues and vices over the
definition of game and not just canvas
they're concerned with choice so if
somebody is generous and they have a
character trait of being generous
they're not just generous once in a
while but they're generous typically
with you as a friend or a family member
or even just an acquaintance of work
somebody there's a new workplace do you
praise them for them you consider that
to be a good thing would you consider to
be a good thing if you found out that
they didn't really have a choice in it
but there was something hardwired in
their brain that just made them that way
or that somebody else was like making
them do that somehow or that they didn't
really realize they thought they were
being generous and you didn't really
they didn't really realize how much
things cost so they're paying money for
launched or something like that and they
get to the end of the whoa get no money
left
would you consider them to be riches
when you consider them to be generous or
would you say they were acting in a nice
way bring the good being out and do you
think they're bad that person either
saying what any normal person might be
thinking but what's a good example
yeah actually that's Arizona let's talk
about about yeah we talked about having
a filter not having an internal sensor
right right some people don't we're
gonna forego the other way we take a
stingy person somebody who is always you
know holding on to their money they're
placed in situations where they could be
generous they pass it up once they
become a parent they're not buy anything
for the kiddies
you think of that as something chosen
someone could they be different like and
I might order by there were younger not
buying things that his money on was
going on vacation once a year that was
nothing else they have been one if like
they would ask them for money it was no
he doesn't happen now he was more money
to say than my parents do he's only 27
like he saved so much that like from
these that he talks his own decision did
you change it or generous have races
like that's more on the sticky side it's
interesting to see that she realizes
there's sort of a process of getting a
better perspective right in order for
somebody to change from being vicious to
being virtuous very often that requires
some sort of change in perspective in
part because the vicious person he
actually sees things wrongly that's part
of what makes them vicious that's what
holds them in the habit and again if the
person didn't have any control over them
let's say there was something hardwired
to their brain that would just made them
stitching
would we consider them to be look at
them as a bad person the way that we
look at the person who chooses to could
do otherwise I don't think so
the Arsenal spoke about something that
fits in with our normal understanding of
now choice fits into it for Arizona when
he's using the word choice she doesn't
mean every single choice that we make
he means the choices that actually form
our character sometimes it's translated
as deliberative choice I like to
translate it as character forming choice
that's word that he's using as a Greek
word for Asus which literally means to
place one thing above or in front of
another so in the case of somebody who
sees going on vacation as you know the
best thing he makes choices over and
over again now I'm beginning other
people so that he can save up for
vacation might work actually in this
case not just say but for vacation to
save up period
so he's saving as battery other things
he prefers might say saving to personal
relationships and being jealous and we
can talk about this in all different
contexts you could say somebody prefers
one physical good over another somebody
prefers a relationship
so they prefer being a certain way or
another way if I decide as I had to
eventually my life I don't want to be
quite such an angry person not just
angry and sense of having the emotion of
not managing well I had to make a choice
what am I going to sacrifice say
indulging myself getting to feel
justified all the time I had to choose
something else better personal
relationships every one of you has made
a big choice that landed you here at
Harris college
you chose to go to college with all the
other things that that entails and work
that you guys are doing over taking it
easy you know some people who haven't
made that choice right or made that
choice that didn't follow through on
that choice and we would say that you're
responsible for that now there's a
broader category that voluntary what is
it our consult what what is it that we
are responsible for and choice the
choices that have frame our characters
to fit into that but this there's no
sure the volunteer is a bit broader so
we want to think about what makes any
action or even an emotional reaction
volunteering brought up this idea about
you know automatic things are you
responsible for your heartbeat no when
you become responsible for your
breathing and it becomes a voluntary
like I said you're in deep trouble there
are some things digestion that better
keep going on whether you think about it
or not right there's a lot of other
things that are involuntary for example
look around the room is anybody wearing
the same outfit as anybody else it could
be it could all be wearing their
superior
everybody can be dressed in olive green
and blue why not we can do that you know
I could coming with that too you know
dr. sailors uniform your class look at
it you know because there'd be some
benefit who knows you have a choice
about right
you thought maybe you didn't think about
maybe just grab the first things you
could [ __ ] you know maybe some of you
actually planned out what you're going
to wear things that you're wearing here
would you necessarily wear them
everywhere like if you were actually
going to play a sports team
poppy should wear that uniform right
otherwise nobody's gonna know some of
the stuff that you're wearing here I
suppose could be business casual if
you're going to be a office and you were
like an executive would you
for the guy that's easy right there's a
high-powered executive I'm not just your
time right soon yeah not just any suit
we're like straight seersucker summer
student playing at a Chautauqua you're
gonna wear like the pinstripe you know
with a nice power type women it's a
little bit more complicated isn't it
exactly you want to wear in the
workplace they actually offer classes on
up at the culinary they have a short
seminar on what exactly is appropriate
business attire because it's so hard to
figure out exactly what you want to wear
what love what's business casual what's
you know totally informal what's like
high-powered you know corporate fashion
all those sorts of things it's kind of
hard to tell for men it's really easy
I have you know fairly limited choices
anywhere suit jacket I wear a sweater if
I want to be you know this is where
flashier
that's what within our choice could
somebody make you wear a particular
thing could they can tell you to do so
certain circumstances I think you'd say
that here to be a prime example if
you're in prison you get to wear
anything you like how about a guard do
you get to wear one of those you put on
one of those and you're in deep trouble
right even if you're like wearing other
stuff you might get your soft
inconsiderable
you have to wear what they issued and
it's interesting because different
states have different different guard
but one of the things that they do
nowadays is the American experience
gonna probably do the prisoners being
transported
orange sometimes together and they
usually have to wear like a job you know
jumpsuit coveralls in that color so you
can identify them do they have a choice
do they get in a sense they could say
strong I'm not going to wear it but then
there's a lot of consequences are so
much less voluntary and this brings us
to the question of what makes something
voluntary
what are you or other people responsible
what do you actually choose what would
you say what do you do responsible or
you stop when do you actually feel good
yeah
go ahead of fire
falling minutes okay I mean like when
you're in a situation do a situation
calls for okay that's an example of
something that couldn't that is
voluntary you're right but the cases
where you you screw up in that way but
you didn't mean to those cases does that
ever happen if any of you we made it
what they call a full pot false step I
make plenty I still make salt you put me
in front of my get really fancy dinner
stuff and I know that you start from the
outside of the forks
so I'm got that part down so you know
but I'm thrifty Midwesterners so I tend
to keep my fork you're not supposed to
do that right
that's a full pot I suppose I could stop
doing what time I did it cuz they didn't
know any better pick whatever fork was
gonna work right different spoons
you're supposed to use it one of the
things that could stand away voluntary
ignorance so when we say that something
is voluntary we often say well it's not
done from ignorance if the person is
actually ignorant and some sense we're
willing to say oh they didn't know they
they're not responsible right well
that's what negative condition yeah hey
don't they do it knowing they know they
have the option so they're conscious of
the range of possibilities because
sometimes people do things and they
don't realize they could adjust I think
that's a kind of ignorance that the
Earth's oil doesn't talk about but in
our society we spend a lot of time
focusing
we need to empower people through your
knowledge right and that wouldn't fit in
with what you're talking about where
that's certainly why we say hey you were
given the information you're responsible
the fact that you say you know know this
you should know right there are
conditions then we're going to get into
those when we say somebody's responsible
what else do we mean
yeah why did you wear that that shirt
and you say well I was playing cards
last night and I happen to win 30 bucks
at poker I said the hell does that have
to do with wearing a shirt I don't know
that's not a reasonable explanation yeah
he said what was my lucky shirt than the
poker game today so yeah I think that is
a component of the aerosol again doesn't
focus on that so much but that's a good
point as well what he really focuses is
the action has its origin in person
where you might think of the active
person is not just the cause of the
action incidentally but the cause of the
action as such the fundamental why did
you wear that shirt because you wanted
it with that shirt does your chose to
wear that shirt you just provide some
explanation for it you didn't put it on
I remember my son one time when he was
little dressing himself and trying to
put a pair of pants sure there is a
clearly he was acting from some sort of
ignorance about the nature of pants and
shirts that you know it's forgivable
because he was like you know you already
have all you have I was asking you to do
a big thing for the kid that age was
just put out a shirt you know there's a
lot of things that are nothing so we
usually excuse the person another thing
is we say that the action is not done
from compulsion the person is not being
forced in some sense to do the action so
when somebody is actually for you the
action we often don't hold them
responsible again you don't think about
the prisoner in the orange jumpsuit we
don't say oh poor fashion choice you
know orange is really had your color in
Perkins they don't have a choice if they
want to get out of their cell and get in
the truck once they have to put on the
orange jumpsuit right there's no two
ways about
that's a very good question well there
are some of us talking about some of
these and this is where virtue advice
come one of the things that that happens
with Vice is the person who is vicious
they not only have a habit of doing the
wrong thing make sure this is think
about providing explanations as well
they have the wrong sort of explanations
for why they're doing the effect that
you actually think that the right thing
is doing so they've mistaken about
they're they're in a state of ignorance
they may actually feel a kind of
compulsion because it before something
happens here but it was what Arizona
says they're responsible for so your
past choices make who you are correct so
if I got that's thank you if I if I
still have a problem with temperance and
I'm willing to tell myself you know
stupid things like it's okay to have ice
cream before going to bed does that make
any sense from from a health perspective
from a weight-loss perspective from a
perspective of self-control when it
comes to food you know I like my dessert
just before I go to bed does that make
any sense yeah somehow I managed to tell
myself yeah that's reasonable let's go
boys cream ice cream would be nice why
is it well I made that choice I made
similar choices
similar choices yeah when it comes to
issues of bodily pleasures having to do
with food time poorly off I'm more
likely to make the efforts of good
decisions on the basis of not seeing the
bad I'm 40 years old so yeah right there
there are there are certain choices that
we make which will then condition our
choices
that's why purchase advices are so
important because they the person who is
virtuous they're on the right track they
probably won't even be that tempted by
the sort of situation of the rest of us
find ourselves in because they already
know what the right thing is to do and
get a hand of doing the right thing good
so here's what ilysm thinks because it
again Aristotle thinks you are
responsible for your virtues and vices
now is iffy if you're completely
responsible that we also know playing
field he doesn't think that but he
thinks that
kind of person I choose to be it could
be much tougher for some people if
you're in a culture where let's say
you're in a culture we are it's expected
of men that whenever they are challenged
they should fight it's probably going to
be more difficult for you to develop the
virtue of genuine courage and you're
going to be much more skewed towards the
vice fool artists making yourself do
aggressive action or you could take a
family situation here
if your parents are particularly
generous and you see them being generous
you're probably much more likely to be
generous yourself could you take that as
a norm if they're Spencer ups there are
constantly like more money they will
bankrupt a couple times you might see
that no big deal you don't see how
damaging that could be to you if there
are tightwads you may see that as the
norm
what miss account that's why it's useful
to have a wide range of experience let's
go look at that ignorance so what do you
be ignorant a lot of things Aristotle
said there's a number of different
particulars that you might be in there
this is really rare but he says that
sometimes you can be ignorant who is
that who's actually doing the action
like your sleep kick you're not
responsible for that did you even know
that you know you were doing that that's
pretty rare but usually got to be in
pretty dire circumstances for that to be
an issue
so for example you were entrusted with
some information you didn't realize it
was a serious situation that the person
wanted you to keep the secret and you
mention it to somebody else and now that
person feels humiliated and angry all
these sorts of things and they said you
told the secret I didn't know it was a
secret you didn't realize what you were
doing you thought you were doing
something else you thought you were just
revealing some information but actually
really bad examples you get really
angered of somebody you're gonna settle
the score with them and you got to
that's a dark alley hit up on the pike
right
and then after worth is the stuff that
block film the water made on it oh it
wasn't that there was so many else oh
you're definitely bad thing now in a
certain sense you did something bad you
hit somebody you should have done that
but you were intending to do something
oh so you're attacking to do a bad
action to Salinas there could be some
cases where that actually that's good
towards one person could be bad for its
another there you you're a doctor and
you think that this patient sitting on
doctors table is person sitting on the
doctors yeah but you've got their chart
and you say oh you didn't injection let
me give you an injection you don't
realize that the charts a bit mixed up
and that guys in the other room this
injection will kill them you don't
realize that until too late why are you
falling over there this would be a lot
of cases
you know the tools that you're using it
means that you're using you could be
mistaken about those you're going to do
some of these taxes or taxes all right
let's say you're up on it yeah they give
you their w-2s and you say oh okay well
this is pretty open shut then 1040ez
there you go and it's not do you think
you're acting with the best tool then
they come to you later on I've got this
whole box of receipts you know they say
does this help at all and you're like I
wish you would have shown this to be a
month ago because then I might advise
and you know go on through the whole
thing with this schedule and a schedule
and use the tech for a itemized you
wouldn't realize that you were acting
you're carrying out something with the
wrong tools what if you have shopping to
us what if you're building something and
you don't realize the materials that
you're building that we're actually
substandard because the store they want
to hold of you thought it would be a
good case see a contractor who purchased
everything on the up and up and the
person what they purchased it from gave
them would that's actually not
pressure-treated the house you know
starts to up to buckles are they
responsible for it
as much as they would be if they know
what do you think this could be one of
those case of reach so you could say
let's say they did their due diligence
another one could be you don't realize
what the goal actually yes
sometimes there's multiple goals and
play you think that you're just
answering some questions on a
questionnaire you don't realize that
this is something they're going to use
to determine whether you're hiring now
they have a different goal which you
don't necessarily share and then there's
also how one is doing in action so we
talked about somebody not knowing their
own strengths and hurting people as a
result that would be an example or if
somebody thinks that they're more
dexterous than they are let's say
they're gonna do something like
tattooing a lot of bad tattoos somebody
did those somebody paid for those
usually sing and the person who was
doing the tattoo nobody comes out says
this is gonna look like crap lined up
you're gonna hate this
let me put it on you but they do it and
they don't realize they're not as good
of a tattoo artist as they thought they
were for the third internship again
maybe they could be responsible and the
key thing is going to be these can
excuse a person provided that the person
themselves is not responsible
or why this is the case so if you
actually came up to me and told me look
you're about to do this and I don't want
to be stubborn and saying no no no I'm
not doing that I'm doing something
different I can't claim ignorance no not
the way I could if I was just wrong in
the situation advice let's think about a
few examples
Aristotle actually talks about a few
which which don't get lost the clerk and
those that stem from vices being
amplified if you've actually made your
selfishness you're responsible for the
ignorance that that vice and clues what
about carelessness so this would be the
sum of the lesson not knowing the
relevant was not paying attention to
relevant aspects of the situation there
are some people who just don't pay
attention to things very well but
they're the kind of person who doesn't
pay attention right I mean if it was
because they're they're mentally
handicapped
we wouldn't hold them as responsible as
somebody who isn't that's why we called
me and again they they are less able to
to pay attention to certain things in
the situation you wouldn't expect an
autistic kid to be as receptive to other
people's emotional states as somebody
who's not autistic
would you that's part of what it means
to be autistic
people's emotional states though maybe
not realizing that the words that are
choosing what you're acting with will
hurt somebody's feelings or maybe not
realizing this is a countable issue with
autistic people quite often can get very
fixated material aspects of their
environment they can see patterns they
can pay attention to things that the
rest of us can't pay as much attention
to as well so they like the patterns on
the floor tiles for example we just
don't pay any attention to it unless
we're steering the Ottoman you start
seeing there's a regular areas there
sometimes people get fascinated with
those and they take the you know
figuring out the pattern is what's
really important not paying attention to
the other people in the situation that
could be a state of ignorance no that
could excuse behavior what an excuse
behavior for me probably done because I
can pay attention to how actions done an
anger or kind of a tricky one that's a
hard one to draw the lines maybe it's
better than that one - till next class
session the actions done little drunk
Aristotle talks about this very quickly
he says hey she always to get drunk I
chose to put yourself in that state of
ignorance it's sort of like if you go
around let's say tomorrow you know
you're a kid you'd like pinatas yes no
fool Academy that's the best thing about
Andy gets a whack but they put the
blindfold on you right and there's kind
of a danger with that isn't there
because especially the younger the kids
aren't suited for that mindfulness
persuade edge you know they might get
the adult because eventually steer them
over to the video pinata and get them to
the like swing around well I may
actually know you did that as an adult
yeah stick they put out of line boys
you're walking around bad things you're
responsible for them right you chose to
put that blind come on that's the way
Aristotle would look at something like
say getting drunk or think about the
effects of various drugs that's actually
a good example to use for it is not
necessarily the the being on drugs but
think about why people use drugs do we
hold them responsible for drug use why
can there be situations where
yeah now that would seem to have more to
do with compulsion although there could
be a component of the ignorance and
people who are our cook top drags are
welcome to tell themselves convenient
lies about their own condition
like I can quit any time I want it's not
really that addictive what else what
else could feed fit into what mistaken
beliefs could one have that would lead
one to start using hard drugs
I think you guys did you have health
class when you were in elementary school
or middle school yeah and I think that
there's an element of compulsion to
ignorance that it's know everybody
around you is saying this is the thing
to do they had some filmstrip that you
watch you know and some teacher that you
see every once in a while at school is
telling you no this is not a good thing
to do it's hard to make that that
knowledge actual isn't it and everybody
else around you let's say your cancer
feels really good that's more reason
people rocks isn't it sometimes they
don't know what the effects are
sometimes people end up trying to one
drive and they don't realize
another construction couple other drugs
some news a possible bird gets handed
the joint that contains PCP they may not
have put themselves in for that you know
one is fairly vile the other one's
pretty hard before let's see what
talking about it another one another
time another case of pigments thank you
you get it all here for plagiarism all
the time right
what is plagiarism he's probably rattle
off a definition for me when the
students plagiarize in your experience I
mean I said exactly the same words
there's that's part but every yeah
sometimes people forget to put the
references in if you're writing a very
long and game through into one process
you can you can sometimes forget these
things sometimes students are actually
not aware of this because it's kind of
hard to see how this could be the case
but sometimes are unaware of what
actually constitutes plagiarism probably
not so much here but at a lower tier
schools and you know we've been try too
bad that I put it in statements about
unless you actually explain it to
students a lot of students don't grasp
the concept
when somebody realizes everything that
you submit something to turnitin.com so
you were to defect why don't have your
rough draft as part of Turnitin because
otherwise I feel always false positive
right so if you were to submit your work
to check it and then you were to submit
submit another later version of it and
your instructor is kind of careless
because they actually tell us what what
similarities there are so I should say
you know so-and-so's essay
31% you know you would be putting
yourself at a disadvantage by using I
don't know I do use it because we're
supposed to use it for though it's kid I
mean we could actually talk about in
some respects let's say we flip the
plate or something
our instructors responsible for
understanding what turn it is actually
telling us let's say I don't get much
attention to it
okay anybody's got above 25 good
automatic that you've got about the 25
automatic gap but it turns out that
would turn a don't you tell us one per
sentence from this number two percent
from this it's not like 25 percent all
came from one single source but let's
say I think of that in part because I
don't know
the waiter me to work so that would be
what you're acting with am I responsible
for the maybe if I'm a grad student
fresh out of college and you know
teaching my four classes and nobody's
mentoring me or anything like that maybe
I can say oh I didn't know but if I'm if
I've been teaching for 10 years and I've
used to run it in before and I have been
at multiple institutions and we've had
workshops Unterman and there's no way I
can claim ignorance that okay I am
ignorant but whose fault is it my own
fault which means that I'm responsible
one for example that I want to use for
endurance before
motion going to college itself one of
the places that I taught before there
was a very little tier school which
means that they were taking in students
who were very unprepared for college
yeah a lot of these students were
first-generation college students from
fairly poor neighborhoods and they had
the impression that if they just got
into college they've made it
they now on the way they're gonna be
doctors and lawyers they were very
unrealistic about their prospects about
the amount of work ahead of them and in
my classes that I was teaching I was
teaching basic level critical thinking
classes where we Dymatize this
specifically i haven't say to them look
if you think that going to college is
going to cut it it's not you actually
have to graduate from college and that
puts that's what the last year that I
talked to a 7% for your graduation
it means 100 students coming in only
seven of them graduated four years
thirty percent of them after six years
so half the students coming in wouldn't
even graduate and part of the reason why
they did that they didn't realize that
it's not enough to go to college you
have to have a degree and then you know
some of those who graduated they sort of
skated by it was an easy school and they
you know they picked classes that we're
gonna be fairly easy and then they think
they're gonna go to med school or
they're gonna get hired by an IBM or
Apple it doesn't work that you actually
have to have skills that you can
demonstrate you know portfolio you have
a great point right you guys know this
because this is sort of common knowledge
they didn't realize that and again this
goes to that question of culpability if
nobody explained that were they
responsible probably not after they made
it through my class they couldn't claim
ignorance they were not responsible so
if they slough them off and was made it
and they refer that 7% graduated in four
years but they didn't acquire any skills
that employers want and nobody wants to
hire them they're responsible for that
condition they can't
let's go down to consider cigarettes
there are some talks about number of
number of things we could be ignorant of
he says that we can be ignorant who the
agent is who's actually acting that's
pretty rare but maybe they don't realize
that they're doing certain facts what
somebody's doing this is a lot more
common it's possible to be unaware of
what you're doing or it's been mistaken
for being something else right you tell
somebody some information that you have
you didn't realize that you were
actually giving away a secret so how
would you describe your action you would
describe your reaction originally it's
just I'm just sharing some information
I'm just filling somebody in you didn't
realize you were supposed to keep that
information confidential you did
something wrong are you responsible if
you didn't know are you responsible what
do you think let's say it's not a case
where
we've actually signed an agreement we're
thinking about for example Sherman all
right you guys all on a purpose dance
party you don't know what it stands for
it's none of us do you know what it what
it means for you right was it being for
you yes getting professors by the way
what for if it means no family
something information that's one one
part work nobody who belongs to this
this institution is supposed to provide
other information about you including
grades class performance
things that you've written without
having some sort of good reason to do so
we're having permission from them so if
your parents for example are concerned
about your grades and they write me what
I have to say to them is I can't tell
you that information I have to get
permission from your son or daughter in
order to reset information to beginning
of this much when I had to sign that
that waiver so that we could record this
this video you guys already have in the
video but your voices are I have to get
permission from each one of you in order
to be able to overcome these because
otherwise I'd be violating in a certain
sense your privacy you have an
expectation of privacy it wasn't like
that by the way back when I was parents
quicken your grades but yet that effect
sometimes now if I try to claim well I
didn't know I couldn't give away your
grades
I don't know I'm giving away these
grades well that's why no because I'm
responsible for my state of ignorance in
that case but if I didn't know let's say
we're not professor student or just
people that know each other from the
street and I say yeah he's doing pretty
good in school we talked to somebody
into that fix class and they said he's
gonna you know even contribute some
class and seems to know what's going on
I wouldn't be violating FERPA rights
I wouldn't be responsible so what
somebody's doing you can automatic what
you're actually up there
what workroom what is acting for
instance you can think that your own
child is a home invader it's one of the
examples I used to Milan these sort of
cases happens right you give money to
somebody who you believe is a good
person to do good things
turns out the third crook are you
responsible for them
well you didn't know digit right what
you're acting with Aristotle is this
great example that probably remembers
from Hamlet having a practice sword and
not really realizing that it's it's a
real sword that the the practice tip
that you're gonna thrust into somebody
there's a heart point out there so you
stick it into something did you mean to
do that
was that your intention you're not
responsible for it it's involuntary what
end you're aiming you you may not have
the same end as other people within the
situation I have this example you might
take a test not realizing that that test
determines whether you get hired you
just think you're taking the test so
you're gonna try to do okay on the test
you don't realize that you shouldn't the
answer certain questions serve unless
you think you're just being honest
you don't realize that maybe it's
reading out certain types of how one is
doing the action when we talk about
somebody not going their own strengths
this would be that that's right right
somebody
well you see this for example many
people some people end up injuring the
babies you gotta handle babies pretty
carefully right matter of fact some
people who have a baby they're like all
shaky is they're they're afraid that's
gonna crack the connect other people
don't realize that you can't just let
the babies not like a stuffed animal you
can't just sit it down and then walk
away
can't hear it was gonna happen was there
like a minute it's gonna fall over until
the age where it sits off and they sit
up like this steady but if you take a
little baby you just stick it there
somewhere it's gonna fall over
it's not like a doll well you know does
everybody know that sort of thing
yeah so there could be some cases where
ignorance is actually causing the
action or I suppose you could have
emotional responses one did any of you
ever got an anger with somebody when you
really didn't have a good classic and
angry with them because you thought they
were saying something that they didn't
really want to say could have been
ignorance right now Aristotle is not
willing to say that whatever your
ignorance of things that you're off the
hook there could be some cases where you
yourself could be responsible so he's
got the example for so let's let's look
at some examples you're out driving and
you're blind drunk and you hit a
pedestrian you didn't see it right
because you're not actually seeing
anything your vision you don't realize
how wrong you are
and you plow into a pedestrian you don't
realize that you were driving on the
sidewalk rather than the road so that's
clearly a piece of ignorance right so
you kids need you it's not your fault is
that we don't say that do we do it
Aristotle was struggling with the same
sort of problem as we do in our own time
if you're ignorant of the situation that
you're in because you've got that
yourself so drunk that you can't tell
where you are or what you're doing
you're responsible for that state of
ignorance aren't you
so Aristotle says he's noting in ancient
Greek cities quite often they doubled
the penalty if you were drunk when you
committed the crime in part because they
had so much problem with people
committing crimes while they were
drunken that saying I didn't realize it
was going on I was drunk worried don't
you get in a bar fight with somebody
because you're drunk and you misheard
what they said and your impulse control
kind of low well you know again nobody
forced you to drink all those those
beers and whiskey's or whatever it is
that you like so in a sense you become
responsible for them what might be some
cases where you're you're not
responsible
what if somebody deliberately lies to
you
what if somebody deliberately places you
in a condition of ignorance are you are
you responsible oh I guess if you could
say that you would still have some
reasonable way to figuring out whether
they were lying to you maybe you could
say that you're responsible but think
about a really good con man do they
usually cover everything every face
right when people get taken in for
instance let's say we look at the
difference between all of you get those
Nigeria what do they call that skin the
Nigerian Bank scam where sometimes it's
Egyptians other places somebody emails
you out of the blue of a city I really
my country
your bank account number sounds better
get emails like that don't you you don't
get those scam things I still get more
so I by this point if you don't know
that to be a scam
you're probably responsible what if
you're an 80 year old person who just
started using the Internet are you is
responsible anything maybe not
what if they follow it up and they don't
do these you know unsophisticated booths
actually misspell the information is
hardly credible but it's somebody that
comes to your door and they talk with
you and you eventually get to know this
person and now they want to carry out a
financial transaction that could be
really lucrative for you but you have to
make yourself vulnerable to that person
in some way financially they credit card
they get to use your name to buy
something
they seem very credible you check them
out you actually go online use for
Darren's or something like that let's
see whether there's any records of them
and they seem perfectly legitimate now
you get scammed and you spent all of
your life savings is that your fault
Eric slot would probably say no again
there's gonna be a lot of situational
factors involved with us what about
things that stems from our cabinets if
we have bad habits that kind of
introduced the state of ignorance can't
wait for vicious people we actually
think here's what makes a vicious person
a vicious person they think that bad
things are good so the coward what a
real column is is somebody who actually
thinks that cowardice is the norm that
everybody else is crazy
for standing up for themselves what
makes a stingy person who actually has
that lysis tanginess the stingy person
is they believe that that's the rational
thing to do that's the best thing to do
they want to be stingy what not to give
other people
like to try to take as much as possible
now if somebody has that's where mind
sets would you say that they're in a
state of ignorance the ignorant about
you know facts of the case or ignorance
about moral realities like you know is
it a good thing to give people
generously or is it a good thing always
hold on to everything and never give
anybody they actually believe that it's
a good thing not to give anybody
anything
maybe they have associated with this one
explain things like it's a tough world
out there nobody's going to eat your
brain they won't mind some of this does
that get them off the hook do we stay oh
they can't help themselves they know
manners
they're just a stage numbers
where do we recurse us
aerosol so to explain them the reason is
they have made themselves that way
by choosing to be stingy over and over
again nobody actually starts out vicious
people become vicious they come to have
a skewed sense of moral realities in
part because they have chosen to do that
over and over again then in situations
where they could have given generously
and they chose the opposite and
eventually they come to convince
themselves but that's the right thing to
do like let's say an angry person the
person who loses their temper all the
time you think about people that you
know in your life don't a lot of angry
people who lose their temper all the
time to tell themselves that that's the
right thing to do they are standing up
for themselves
everybody else should do the same thing
of their situations well that's probably
a state that's probably a sign that
they're vicious and they're in a state
of ignorance but how did they get to be
that well they chose to give in to that
anger over and over again and on some
level they chose to buy into the
justifications and longer than you do it
the more that you do it the easier it
gets to be to justify these things the
first time they can do something wrong
and you want to justify it to yourself
that it didn't work really well think
again think back when you were a kid get
something bad you knew it was bad after
you did it and start to feel some
remorse
then you told yourself anyway it was
okay for me to do that did you buy it
the first time you slip that to yourself
did you still feel bad when you did it
there after you did it now imagine you
do that over and over and over again it
gets easier and easier doesn't it when
you lie to yourself about basic things
about yourself right wrong it's sort of
like you know changing a pattern
eventually you change from one pattern
to a different pattern so this is a good
place to actually to go away from these
examples of my ignorance and think about
virtue advice or or choice the eros
level says that that we in addition to
the voluntary the involuntary which we
can actually contribute to children
there is the the realm of the chosen
deliberate choice and this is a little
bit more restrictive you might think of
what he's calling choice he has
character for me choice where I have a
choice he uses this term fry raíces
which literally means to choose one
thing instead of another so I'm choosing
to be a courageous person rather than to
be a colorist we're choosing to be a
courageous person rather than choosing
to be a foolhardy person so he says
Pro racists or her choice ultimately
involves something that he calls
deliverer deliberation we think about
whatever roles we do this we've talked
about this a lot this semester right we
think about our goals in immediate
situations but here your goal is to
finish this class graduate from Mayoress
get a job why do you want to do that
just for its own sake you just went to
college just you know college yeah you
got to be able to come up with a whole
bunch of reasons you're a little burnt
out we engage in deliberate choice we're
thinking about those bigger acts so we
form ourselves we make ourselves into
certain kinds of people depending on
what we take as our main and if you
could you take wealth is your mana
you're more likely to end up being
stingy right being generous if on the
other hand you think that providing for
your family is important and you're
probably have a much more measure the
attitude towards money and then when it
comes to your kids coming to you and
saying like an xbox and they actually
make some swears reason appeal there's
PlayStation sorry you can actually say
yeah okay that seems like a reasonable
expense for the amount of pleasure that
you're going to get out of it let's go
out to the store and get it rather than
saying we don't spend money in this
house that will form who you are those
sort of choices made over and over again
are going to form the kind of person so
you know again people don't start out
fair or unfair we all start out with
certain capacities but then we build on
the choices that we make and we often
have to think about
deliberate one of the things that comes
into deliberation quite a lot is what
kind of person do I want
do I want to be the cat person who does
good things or did I want to be the kind
of person who says I'm going to do
whatever I want to which will eventually
become you know doing vicious things
sooner or later
we saw just a minute ago that there's
two ways that they can compulsion one
would be to think of some sort of
external force being applied maybe
physical may be psychological another
way to think of it is some sort of
psychological they'll be physically
doing something inside of you right will
be to use that example would be
something that you felt a compulsion
about getting your parents to buy you in
a store maybe not to know this last week
but sometimes kids because I really want
that's where the thing actually
commercials are set up to make kids
that's why they cartoons and then almost
immediately after the cartoon there'd be
like the action figures for that cartoon
they want you to get your parents though
yeah some sort of psychological desire
so we can talk about an external force
apply to you in some way and we can talk
about some internal force some
compulsion no Eric's local has a few
other examples so he talks you know he's
using examples from his home time he
talks about somebody who was sailing and
wind blows him to a port that he doesn't
want you he didn't choose to end up
there right the wind question that that
direction
that's compulsion that's an external
force another person grabbing a person's
hands smacking them who's brought data
that's an example compulsion if I had
some sort of you know box that let me
say it's like a PlayStation that's what
sort of controller that let me control
all of your movements because there was
a chip in the back of your head would
you be responsible for your movements in
that case I would be responsible for I
would be the one who's who's making you
do the things that you do and notice in
each of these cases we do have the same
sort of pattern where there's some
action something that happens and then
there's the person doing the action but
then we say that there's some sort of
force making the person do the act
the reason why we say in the case of the
compulsion that the person is not
actually responsible for their actions
is because we trace back the qualities
we set the chain of cause and effect to
whatever it was that forced a hand so if
it's the wind that blew you off course
you were sailing you wanted to get
I don't know already sail to around here
the Great Lakes
and you want to sail - to Florida and
then wound up in the Bahamas instead the
wind was responsible right you didn't
you didn't choose them if I grabbed your
hand and I smacked somebody else
like some other way of making your body
do certain things you're not responsible
for that action I'm responsible it gets
a little bit more interesting when we
think about emotions because you know
remember Aristotle talking about virtues
and vices when somebody makes you angry
you've all been I've already been still
angry that you've done things that you
regret it later and sometimes you
realize yeah that was me I could have
chosen not to do that but I did do it
other times you actually felt like you
couldn't possibly not do that some of
you may have to go back to when you were
kids
last week we would often say well it's
the person who angered me who is really
responsible for this
Aristotle's actually kind of perceptive
he thinks there's certain things you
want to get angry about and so if you
are angry it could be the club it could
be because somebody else thoughtlessly
or deliberately provoked you aerosol
says we get angry could often people put
us down is a verb that means to so quite
a lot of when you get angry it's because
you feel that somebody else is devalued
they're treating you in a way that you
don't like to be treated probably think
they would like to be treated as well if
we want to say that compulsion is
involved in that case we would actually
have to say that this person is
responsible the angering person like for
example let's think about the
determinant case bully topic that's in
the news what happens with kids that are
bullied
does it produce any changes in that over
time what kind of changes
yeah I think you're right in most cases
the kids that are being bullied don't
end up fighting back today they ended up
you might say succumbing to bully and we
use this as an example we're talking
about courage one second so if we want
to talk about the person becoming more
and more vulnerable less and less able
to resist the bullying and we won't look
at that as a kind of course of action
and we say are they responsible for it
does their parents might say hey [ __ ] up
you know stand up for yourself you're
responsible for this this kicks that
oftentimes the victim to blame to them
in that case we would be saying that
that person is fully responsible and
we'd be ignoring the back end of this
why are they faced with that situation
in the first place because somebody's
bullying them usually it's not just one
person right how does it actually work
in you guys are you know three years out
of high school how does it work in
middle school or high school
the kid is bullied only believe by one
person usually it's a life
once somebody starts getting bullied
what happens to them maybe your high
school is very different from high
school yeah
yeah once in situations where we use
this kind of I don't want to say
necessarily buy that's all I could
involve in physical violence but
intimidation tearing people down that
sort of thing
once somebody doesn't fight back other
people who want to do that sort of
things see them as an easy mark and
they'll do it now too and that makes it
even worse right an intensive classic we
go
sometimes yeah and does that work very
well
yeah and sometimes appearances say stuff
like don't give them the satisfaction of
making you angry right don't don't let
them know that it's getting to you I'm
gonna leave you alone and then sometimes
I suppose that works in my experience
I've never actually seen it work but I
suppose there's cases where it does the
person stayed after a while how
voluntary is that how voluntary is the
condition of their place given being in
one sense we might say well if they
don't like that they're they're
responsible for the situation that
they're at but again I think that's
ignoring in fact that there's another
person in here or four people who are
actually choosing to hurt that other
person the person choosing to tear them
down anticipating their responses right
person does for example say ignore them
then what do they do they act some more
use that against them call them
different names in a sense I think Aris
level might be receptive to this he
would say the sort of things that we
experience with bullying are more the
responsibility the person is doing the
bullying then the person is being
bullied that in a sense it's kind of
there's something morally wrong or we
walk with blaming the victim in these
cases what about cases where the bullied
person fights back how does that often
go I mean sometimes it's it's fairly
measured I think you've all seen that
the internet video where that big kid
was getting bullied by this little kid
and then he punches him and a little
kids you know like crumbles because it
was a big kid yeah but he was being
bullied for day after day after day
after day does he go over there and
start you know stopping him then he
doesn't he stops right then I always
held believed kids react when they
finally quit taking it I remember a kid
when I was in high no middle school and
we were playing baseball I don't know
what happened there's awful sort of
things where somebody one of the mean
kids got an idea
and the kid was wearing a jacket
everybody started spitting on his back
one person did it and you know you turn
around and the other person would do it
from behind and the kids getting manner
of man is this this kid had been picked
on and bullied for at least you know a
semester so he was the transfer student
there always you know using her marks
and finally that he started to you know
knock it off you started seeing space
get read you could tell he was getting
more and more agitated understandably so
right would any of you like did you have
that happen to you yeah I mean it's also
be it knock it off and then the next guy
behind you does that and they turn
around with it to him and somebody else
does it that would infuriate after a
while well he ended up picking up a
baseball bat and if he had connected I
think he probably would have killed a
[ __ ] because he was swinging you know
pretty hard he was he was you know in a
fury and luckily he didn't connect whose
fault would it have been if he actually
did you know that's worth thinking about
yeah
Aristotle might be willing to say in a
case like that but it's actually the
fault of metals for me and a lot of
times it in law that's right
and you could say that in a sense ease
of irresponsible in a sense that are
responsible yes all is also receptive to
that but the more that it becomes
something like somebody else calling the
shots somebody else forcing the
situation the less responsible the agent
becomes now if somebody had just you
know mouthed often some of these pics of
a bad start hitting people
Aristotle said that's not a sufficient
provocation to
well Aristotle is willing to say that
there are some psychological pressures
that as he calls a overstrained human
nature so there would be some people you
know state for instance we took Gandhi
right and did this to God and you got me
with a baseball bat okay but Gandhi is
you know this incredibly disciplined
person who you know developed this this
was habit of non-violence that took a
lot of work to do that as a matter of
fact he writes about being angry and
then wanting a strength back early on
this period he has to realize that this
kid was you know twelve years old
doesn't fully have impulse control
development know very often these are
kind of hard cases I think we could be
at least agree that the bullies bear
more responsibility for how the things
go now if again if it had been a
different sort of situation if this kid
had deliberated said what can I do to
send a message
to do it that I usually probably would
say yeah now he's more responsible
legged Oh think back to when you were
very young Columbine shootings those
those kids they formed a plan they were
being bullied they felt a lot of pain
anguish anger psychological pressure but
that didn't mean that they actually go
out
trenchcoats guns make a plan of going to
the school I think that's a pendings
that's some way different than somebody
just picking up a bat that's handy and
starting to swing if they are so not
saying any these are good things he's
not saying everything is OK
he's interested in tracing out who's
ultimately responsible let's look at a
few other examples that have to do with
compulsion he talks about the acting out
of fear and here Aristotle is again a
bit less receptive to saying well it's
entirely the fault of the person who
made the other person frame if I
threaten you
I'm going to give you an F in this glass
unless you
report to be on the habits of your
classmate follow your classmate around
shadow them and then write a five-page
report at the end of the semester I'm
gonna count density your final paper if
you don't do it you have a choice in the
matter
hey let's say you do follow me around
what are you doing why are you following
me around why are you taking notes up
I'm gonna report for dr. Sandler why do
you think that well he said that if I
don't do this I'm gonna get it after
this oh that's okay then violate my
privacy all your life
that's a dumb kid because you were under
compulsion
be a good person well
it's from Aristotle's respect if he
never talks about this as far as doesn't
really in general yes that would that
would be a less praiseworthy there just
be a type of punishment right it's
displacing the punishment to the
afterworld instead of in this life it's
sort of like saying I'm going to knock
shop with is that when I go to jail
you should have shopped in part because
it's bad thing to do and you can
recognize the badness and you can you
know say value your relationship with
the storekeeper and all these other
things are gonna be better holders let's
say let's say we change it a little bit
let's say somebody is a very religious
person that they haven't done a lot of
thinking about religion and they're very
prone to accept authorities and programs
because when you when you get into this
is sort of side now when you get into
the theology who's going to have an
inclusive anyhow it gets pretty
complicated invert it's not so
absolutely cut and dry to some people to
make it out to be tradition
well let's say you've got a person who
is fairly susceptible to taking for
granted whatever
authorities say so some religious
authority says to this person if you
don't go kill that other person you're
going to help that person is an
abomination they are doing horrible
things
maybe they that's Russell Eisen you know
they they're they desecrated this this
you know religious area over here
they've raped killed murdered stolen all
these sorts of things if you don't kill
them you're going to hell because you're
just as bad as people make these sort of
arguments at times or let's say they
they'll offer you the prospect of what
he comes person you don't have it I
suppose that Aristotle would be willing
to say that if this person is of the
sort that really believes that sort of
thing but the other person would be more
responsible let's say they can walk to
an environment where this is this is
done thing would be less responsible for
their their action less responsible I
don't think he would say it's fairly
responsible and this one would actually
tie in a little bit more ignorance I
think too there are certain things about
which we really want not to be there
we'll get to that and just one second I
want to think of one other example of
compulsion that we could sow acting out
of here are some big consequence if one
doesn't act that way Aristotle says you
do have some to us so let's say we're at
the ATM I come up behind you it's a dark
night and I've got a knife I say take
these days but take it out I'm robbing
you could you know you do have some
measure Troy that's right because hey
Surya do whatever I want
am I going to give you my money you
could do that right good lesson there's
other things you could do to like you
couldn't you know pretend like you're so
nervous that you drop the card and you
can't remember the combination of might
the other things that you do but let's
say actually if you don't remember the
combination reduce it to it yes or no oh
that's interesting that's worth checking
out not actually just in case you never
forget because that's one of those
learner bits of knowledge that unless
you had it sort of handy you wouldn't
remember to do that a scary situation
how many of you do you think would
actually say to the the robber I'm not
going to do it
if you did why would you do it I mean
I've I knew somebody who wants to
actually did something like that she she
was robbed in Milwaukee a bad part of
Milwaukee and this kid wanted her walk
cadet and she said I'm not gonna give
you the wall I'll give you the money
because you didn't use that I'm not
giving you the credit cards not giving
you the rest of the law because it's got
all my idea
and it takes a long time to get new IDs
and it's a big pain if you don't have
any of these at all when they're in here
and I'm not giving you the credit card
first thing I would do is cancel them
any way that I'm not going through the
process of having to void the cards wait
for new cards to show up particularly if
I don't have any ID I'll give you the
money
I'll give you this you have like 80
bucks I'll give you the 80 bucks and she
was very nervous when she did this
before she was feeling fear right
because somebody was trying to compel
her kid was she said the kid was
actually kind of nervous as well but I
mentioned up her right somebody there's
you know 16 years old but thirty years
old it was done this you know dozens of
times
that takes a lot of guts that is
possible to do them it's difficult and
Aristotle would say there's no hard and
fast line here again we've run into that
of that situation of does it overstrain
human nature how much would your sense
of fear sort of flood over you and force
you to do this no if you had banded
through the military do you think
be easier for you to face that sort of
situation been through boot camp you
know our basic training whatever the Air
Force calls about they call it used to
make fun of them quite up to smoke it
would probably the easier it would be
more responsible for your actions in
that situation the viewer saw
eighteen-year-old kid on campus for the
first time ever hear of your home town
which was a small town now you're in the
big city and suddenly you're you're
being bug
are you as responsible for your behavior
when you hear this word compulsion what
do you think
ignorance is not doing things right
those compulsion yeah
what are we more ignorance wouldn't ya
curious curious about the effect I
suppose of curiosity it's all because of
a compulsion like some people can't help
them so they can't tear themselves away
from looking at the road crash now I'm
sure to get towards one meeting okay so
it could be lack of control over one
interface over your actions what's doing
the control okay so this would go to the
curiosity thing we often use this and
describing situations of temptation and
what's tempting us what do we what do we
need to tribute that to curiosity could
be a desire to find hard to resist what
else
what temperature I supreme temps me
I've got something tasty for you come to
the refrigerator scoop me out yeah I
think there are some things that a lot
of pain we might do a little bit of
curiosity under that rubric you know
pleasure and it's whether there's some
sort of drive or temptation or desire
and we often feel it's overpowering us
it's it's making us do this
maybe our emotions those are things
inside of us so we usually say you're
right they could be outside
- it's like pushing the refrigerator
open around the corner today come sample
pink
I'm tasty right it's external to me but
my desires are inside of me my desire
what else okay psychological force and
here someone uses the if I grab here of
your hand and I whack somebody else face
with it you didn't actually willingly
whack somebody in the face matter of
fact you may be very surprised you know
imagine like the situation like that
somebody's laying on a massage table
they're they're getting a massage and
then somebody takes their hand and
there's somebody sitting next to them
what was that
oh I'm sorry but you're you're less
sorry that you did it that your hand in
it you're more starting that you were
used as an instrument right maybe maybe
you will actually feel a little bad that
I should resist it but yeah oh did you
that that person was going to do that or
even let's say they did let's say
somebody's much stronger than you
holding your wrist
you're not responsible what if they had
like a little thing inside your brain
that made you do certain things again we
wouldn't say you're responsible there's
no external force and sometimes that
external force
be psychological peer pressure can be
difficult to resist aerosol is willing
to talk about certain things which as he
puts to overcome human nature over over
master human nature there are some
things where not everybody but most
people will find themselves unable to
actually resist them try to find that
actual quote because it's a good one
over strains human nature that's the
best assurances different emotions can
do that fear so let's end there
have a good break have a good Easter
we'll pick up with the actual virtues
and vices